[Music]
i don't know if this is the right time
and place just let me know if you want
to discuss it later but uh
i love to talk with you for a little bit
about minimalism and privilege just
because i saw a question the other day
in response to one of our videos where
somebody said and i can read it if i can
uh
get my phone but somebody said i would
like to see you all talk about
minimalism for poor people
because a lot of this sounds like a
bunch of people that have a lot of money
and they think that spending it on
expensive things is what's going to make
them happy but this seems to be a
problem only for the privilege and what
about people who
aren't even there yet where they need
minimalism because they're still trying
to get to the point of getting the bare
minimum
minimalism does involve the stuff at
least on the surface but it's much more
about the desire
that we have for the stuff as you know
ryan and i grew up really poor you can
see it in our last netflix film
you can see the house i grew up in which
is just totally crumbling falling apart
and it was crumbling and falling apart
when i was living there
back in the 80s and 90s
and we grew up really poor and the
problem wasn't necessarily a lack of
things
it was a desire
for the things that we thought were
going to solve the problems that we had
and it turns out in my 20s when i
climbed the corporate ladder i made
enough money to get many of those things
the really nice car the oversized house
literally the white picket fence
those things didn't make me satisfied or
fulfilled in fact they often did the
opposite because the desire for more
didn't go away and so there's nothing
inherently wrong with money right money
can certainly buy you comfort it cannot
buy you satisfaction or fulfillment or
happiness it can buy you temporary burst
of pleasure but what does that do that's
hedonism if our threshold for pleasure
continues to increase and increase and
increase that ends up making us
miserable the reason i was even more
miserable in my
20s
wasn't because i was poor i wasn't poor
anymore but i was broke
because i carried those habits from my
childhood forward and i realized that
oh no amount of money
is going to make me a better person a
more complete person
and i've been really touched by the
people who i've gotten emails from but
they said i realize that i'm striving
for something
that is not going to make me happy thank
you for allowing me to catch that before
i went down the same path that you and
ryan went down trying to achieve in fact
the etymology of the word agony
means to strive
and so
no wonder we're all walking around in
extreme agony all the time because we're
striving for something
that isn't going to satisfy us now
that's not to minimize the fact that
there is poverty in this world and
there's extreme poverty outside the
borders of america right i grew up in
probably the bottom five percent maybe
in the bottom two percent of poverty in
america extreme poverty
but it's nowhere near what you see in
bangladesh or india or in the congo
right and and so it's all relative
privilege becomes relative in that sense
as well and what i love about something
that you've said tk we have a video on
our youtube channel called
your privilege is irrelevant it was a
quote from you and you were talking
about yes privilege is a real thing
but simply using that term oh you are a
privileged person or you are a white cis
heterosexual male or whatever these
things become
thought-terminating cliches here's how
i'm going to shut you down i'm not going
to open up the conversation with you
because well i'm going to judge you for
not who you are but who i identify you
as well here's what i'll say about
minimalism and poverty
minimalism is applicable to anyone who
is discontented with the status quo i
personally growing up poor would have
benefited much more from minimalism
living a meaningful life
within my means don't you don't have to
call it minimalism call it living within
your means-ism but being intentional
with your resources
is always a recipe for finding
contentment because the contentment
isn't out there externally the
contentment is right here i simply have
to uncover that contentment and if you
make a million dollars a year which i've
never done in my life
if you are intentional with those
resources it's going to get you farther
if you make ten thousand dollars a year
my mom never made more than thirty
thousand dollars a year ever
and yet we could have been way more
deliberate with our resources here's one
last anecdote for you
when i walked away from the corporate
world i was making really good money in
the corporate world that was broke
massive amounts of debt when i walked
away i'd finally paid off all of my debt
after a four-year plan of really
being strict on my budget
that first year i made 23 000
i took almost a 90
pay
decrease but i was more financially
sound that year than i had been the last
decade of making quote-unquote good
money because i was now in control
of my resources
that's right on i'm gonna make a
controversial statement here and say
the notion that
minimalism is a message only for the
privileged
is itself a privileged assertion that
can only be
made
if one is out of touch with the real
conditions that bring about poverty
the power of consumerism
not consumption
the power of consumerism is that it
shapes our core assumptions and
ambitions about life itself and it
orients us towards the world in a
particular way so that we pursue
particular kinds of things we value
particular kinds of things and we see
ourselves in particular kinds of ways
and this hurts the poor more than the
rich because the rich can actually
afford to be stupid in ways that the
poor cannot
it's like if you got a lot of leeway
when you're starting out a business you
can take a lot of risk you can go
without making profit for several months
and still stay in business and have time
to figure it out if you don't have a lot
of leeway you can't afford to absorb the
same kinds of risk that people with more
financial resources can and i would
argue that this hurts the poor far more
than the rich because it orients the
poor
towards the world in a way that
reinforces the kind of illiteracy that
must be overcome in order to create
wealth and i don't just mean reading
literacy i mean economic illiteracy
financial illiteracy and so on and so if
you live a life where you're just
constantly bombarded
with ads telling you to buy nike that
this is the kind of person that you're
supposed to be if you ever get the money
this is what you're supposed to do with
it uh if you ever pursue money this is
why you should pursue it but it gives
you no information at all about how to
create nike how to invest in nike how to
create alternative systems to the ones
that you observe
you're bound to remain part of this same
system with nothing more than the hope
of one day getting to be a better
consumer you don't consume your way out
of poverty you create your way out of
poverty most of these advertisements
aren't empowering people to be better
creators yeah that's beautifully said
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free